بعد اكتشاف استعداد الاصابه بمرض الزهايمر
اعلن نجم هوليود الاسترالي كريس هيمسورت
البلد من العمر 39 عاما انه يخطط للتوقف
عن تمثيل وربما الاعتزاله المبكر جاء هذا
القرار بعد خدوعه لفحوص دقيقه اثبتت ان
لديه استعدادا وراثيا للاصابه عوامل
وراثيه تجعله اكثر عرضه للاصابه بعشر مرات
مقارنه باي شخص اخر
واكد انه يرغب في انهاء شخصيه الثور التي
يجسدها في عالم مارفل السينمائي قبل ان
يتم تشخيصه بشكل رسمي بانزايمر ليضع نهايه
ممتازه للشخصيه قبل فوات الاوان حسب قوله
هذا الاعلان صلى الظهر
الذي بات لا يعرف عمرا وقد يصيب الاشخاص
في سن صغيره فيما يعرف المبكر
[موسيقى]
شو هي الاعراض اللي بتشكل جرس انذار للفرد
او للشخص انه قد يصاب بادزايمر في
المستقبل القريب وعامر صغير
يعني عندما يلاحظ الاخرون ان هناك تغيرات
في سلوك هذا الفرد وفي ذاكرته
بعد ما هو
كثيرون يقولون
اننا بدانا ننسى ولا نتذكر هذا الذي يتعرض
له الكثيرون حتى صغار السن في عمر
المراهقه فهو النسيان ناتج من من يعني
طبيعه الحياه اللايف ستايل
يعني التي غيرت كثيرا من الاشياء التلوث
البيئي والتلوث الالكتروني هذا لا يعني
انه الزهايمر ليس هناك ههه علامات تؤكد
تماما انه الزهايمر همم لكن اول مؤشر هو
عندما يلاحظ همم الاقربون لدى هذا الشخص
ان ان بعض السلوكه قد تغير انه اصبح لا
يهتم بنفسه انه اصبح لا يستطيع يعني اداء
بعض المهام حتى يعني بسيطه همم هذا هو
مؤشر
لكن الان هناك يعني بعض الفرصات الدقيقه
في السابق كان لابد ان تعمل يعني رنين
مغناطيسي وضيقي واشياء متقدمه او ما يعرف
بالبيتسكان لمعرفه الترسبات البروتينات في
خلايا الذاكره
لكن يعني هذا العام ثم
اكتشافات يعني
يعني
تشخيص اكثر سهوله وفي السابق كانت تشخيص
الا بعد الوفاق والان هناك ايضا علاجات
جديده يعني حتى يعني هذا
حسام همم عليه ان لا يستسلم ان هناك الان
اجسام مضاده
بالبروتينات
استخدامها اذا تاكد انه الزهايمر يعني
التشخيص او ان هذه الجيل الموجود هل هو
فعال ام لا يعني حتى وجود التحورات في
الجينات لا يعني
ان نقضيها الزهايمر لكن ترسبات البروتينات
الان يمكن اجراء فحوصات عليها في الدم اذا
وجدت هذه البروتينات المتكسره الدم بواسطه
التقنيات حديثه اا يمكن له ان ياخذ بعض
العلاجات التي تمنع يعني تكسرها
في خلايا الذاكره